hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and happy new year
2018 so uh it's been a while what like a
week week and a half since our stream so
we're gonna jump back into that main
project that we were working on so I
have it up on the screen now the this is
what will end up being franciscan dot
edu so today I want to try to just make
a layout for the homepage right now you
know we don't have much right we have
our hero section but you know we kind of
just threw these in I think they were
just left over from some code that we
copied in from a previous project so I'd
like to do first I'd like to explain
like what I'm thinking get your feedback
on it and then we'll try to build it out
where we're not gonna use like any real
data we'll just kind of like you know
hard code some lorem ipsum in there or
something I just would like to give my
boss you know some something to look at
like a real site they can scroll through
and look at and and see what he thinks
I've discussed some some design options
with him before Christmas and I made
some sketches just in a notebook so
that's what I'm gonna go from they're
just they're really rough I haven't
thought everything out completely so
we'll just test it out and see what
works so I'm gonna check the live chat
before we get started just to say say hi
to everyone everybody
we do have a question which music app
you guys use I just switched to google
play music is Spotify is not available
in my country and I was able to pay for
the premium membership using in Indian
credit card a school yeah I use Spotify
I'm using Spotify right now
I like Spotify I definitely I enjoy the
Spotify Premium so there's no
commercials I've tried out google play
music before as well it was maybe two
years ago that I tried it I think to you
maybe it was only a year I can't
remember it was at least a year ago
maybe more so I don't know what it's
like now if has changed a lot but I'm
definitely happy with with Spotify but
if you don't have Spotify I think you
know Google Play Music is good I always
I used to listen to Pandora all the time
- you don't I don't know if they've
changed Pandora but I mean it's not the
same as Spotify where you can select the
song you want it was always kind of
random songs so a little bit different
there but it's still nice okay
Oh Philip listen says he listens to
music on YouTube actually I used to do
that too sometimes people put on some
nice like mixes on YouTube sometimes I
hear songs on YouTube that I couldn't
find on Spotify or really anywhere else
and I still have to go back to YouTube
to listen to it
oh man harsh it said Pandora's also
blocked there well I guess Google music
might be your best bet then alright one
more question and then we'll get started
let's see how would use this is from
Bernardo how would you describe the
learning curve of react when compared to
angular or view okay so I'm gonna answer
this question but I want everyone to
know I tried to learn react alone like
years ago so or I'm sorry I tried to
learn angular years ago I was not nearly
as good with JavaScript so this I don't
have an equal comparison here but I
found react a lot easier to learn than
angular but just take that for what it
what it is I tried to learn angular 1
when I was just kind of new with
JavaScript I tried to learn react after
I had been working with JavaScript for
years so that may account for it for the
difference in you know my ability to
learn it I have not tried out any of the
newer versions of angular though so I
don't know that my answer is really that
helpful
all right oh so I saw Philips comment in
the chat reminded me so Philip made a
Pomodoro clock the Pomodoro timer here
so we've been using Harsha's timer which
is awesome and now Philip sent me the
link to this on Twitter and we'll just
check this out
you know quickly before we start because
it's cool so basically I mean apartment
order timers is pretty basic you know a
nice the starter 25 minute timer you
know you put in your brakes your short
and long breaks and you need to be able
to start and stop the timer right super
easy I don't mean it's easy to build I
just mean like the concept is easy right
but this is a cool feature I haven't
seen on a Pomodoro timer before and
Harshit if you have this on yours
forgive me I just haven't haven't seen
it but there's a dark theme on the
Pomodoro timer and if you've watched
this before you all know how much I like
the dark themes for pretty much
everything I mean even my office is dark
all the time and actually the paint is
you can't tell because the lights are
off and the camera is not facing a wall
but all the paint in my office is darker
than anybody else's office in this
building sighs I came in when it was
still under construction and they had
already painted it I was disappointed
because I wanted darker colors and then
I noticed that somebody had accidentally
spilled splattered paint all over the
walls so then I got talked to the guy in
charge of the construction and I said
hey well you got to repaint this anyway
right and so I ended up getting all the
dark the dark paint but anyway I'm sure
y'all didn't didn't need to hear that
story but my point was I just think the
dark themes cool so thanks for sharing
that with me Philip that was really cool
maybe we'll use this one today and if
anybody else has any cool Pomodoro
timers that you made maybe we'll feature
new ones as as you all come up with
new ones then just send them to me and
as long as they work we use them wow I
got a lot of activity alive yet okay I
want to I'm just gonna just very briefly
check out the live chat see if there's
anything I should address now before we
start okay pretty much a lot of talking
about music players someone someone has
studied to master JavaScript to apply
for junior web developer job no you
don't need to master anything to apply
for a junior WebDAV over I think sorry
I'm drinking a lot I have a sore throat
having coughing so I don't want to like
cough a lot during the stream so I asked
some coffee here no I don't think you
need to master JavaScript you just you
need enough to be able to do what they
need you to do for the job someone
that's what I was drinking yes coffee
right now
okay here's a question that I probably
should answer before we start what is
material design so I think I put it in
the title of this video material design
is the design principles I guess that
Google developed for for all of its
products so if you look at a lot of
Google's products you you can see
similarities right so let's take a look
just within this I mean you can see you
have a certain shadow here to this card
so their items that are in look like
they're raised off of kind of the
background and these are called cards in
material design they have a certain
shadow that makes them appear to be a
certain height off of the the background
or with you know with in material design
you can call it the paper it has you
know the same border radius on
everything the buttons behave the same
so like there's it's this unified
framework I don't want to go too much
into the philosophy of it because I
think we've covered it on previous
streams but if you check out Google's
page on material design and you'll they
have a lot I mean there's pages and
pages and pages of examples and you're
them explaining why they do it this way
but that's what I mean by material
design it's it's Google's design you
know framework so that's what we're
using and mic hook says accidentally
splashed paint was it you it was not me
I did not scratch the paint but that
would have been a good idea but it was
somebody else
all right so let me get started now
since we've I've done quite a bit of
talking here at the beginning so where's
that timer let's use this summer so I'm
gonna start this Pomodoro session I'm
gonna code for 25 minutes
then I'm going to take a five-minute
break I'm gonna come back to the live
chat answering your questions so if you
put a question in there and I haven't
got to it yet please just be patient I
will get to it if I can't get to
everything in that 5-minute break
I'll get to it at the end but after that
5-minute break we'll do another 25
minute session we'll try to get to
Pomodoro sessions in today and then
after that we'll do all
question-and-answer if you can't stick
around till the end of this stream
you'll be able to watch I'll answer all
your questions at the end even if you're
not here and you can just watch the
recording later on the video will be
available on the free cooking YouTube
channel ok so let me just just a minute
or two explanation of kind of what my
boss and I were talking about so his
idea was to have the front page be let's
say like dynamic so what would he means
by that is he wants it so that when you
come to the page there's gonna be
different content there and so it won't
be let me restart this let me say first
of all the main target audience for this
site for this page are gonna be students
like prospective students so mostly
people in high school that might want to
come to this university right all right
so having said that the look and feel of
this is almost gonna seem like somewhat
I don't know I don't want to say like a
social media thing it's because it's not
but it's almost gonna have like a
Pinterest style of lots of different
things being there but it's going to be
it's gonna look more random than it
really is
so you'll see this as we get started but
the idea is that people might have
incentive to come back to to the site to
see what's new but we do want to make it
obvious that hey you can apply so like
this button here will say apply now
right so we want to make it the the
message of the site the marketing
message is obvious we want you to apply
but there's also going to be a lot of
other stuff that you can check out on
this homepage of course if you know what
you want you can always go to the menu
and go right to it all right so that's
kind of the idea so here's how it's
gonna work I don't even know if this is
worth it I don't think you'll be able to
see this - no it's like even if you can
see this guess it's not very impressive
so I'll just do my best to explain so
what we would have is a bunch of cars
kind of like what we have here we have
some cars but we would have cards of
different shapes and sizes all in here
kind of in like not like a grid is in
everything being the same but you know
you've seen those kind of like mosaic
type grids where you have some cards
will be wider or taller than the other
cards everything just fits in that's
what we're gonna have so we may have a
large card here let's say that's a
section for events and we pull the data
from wherever we're getting our events
which may be in WordPress maybe we're
pulling it from our like Eventbrite or
something and it would list a bunch of
the events have some little thumbnails
right and then maybe in in this section
we'd have two smaller cards right and
one of the cards would be like a fact
about Franciscan like I don't know like
95% of Franciscan graduates or like find
a job within the first year I don't know
if that's true but we would have some
impressive sounding fact about
Franciscan there and we these could
rotate you know
we could have a custom post type in
WordPress about Franciscan facts right
and we could just get a random one every
time something like that right and then
another section
you know another card could be a video
right video tour of one of the dorm
rooms or something you know or of canvas
or you know whatever and then you just
go down with these different cards so
some things would change like obviously
when you come back there would be
different events here as time goes on
but it would be basically static that
you know you're always going to be able
to find the events here there'd always
be a fact right there but it may be a
different one than you saw before same
way there might be a video might be a
different one you know potentially we
could have it so that I hate to do this
because it reminds me of having a slider
but possibly you could have it so people
could click through and see all the
different facts you know that's the
possibility as well or you can have it
so that there's a fact card here and
then scroll down the page a little bit
more and there's another one over here
potentially we could just throw in nice
pictures of campus it could be switched
in and out you know seasonally so that
in wintertime you see in pictures of
campus with snow on the ground all right
so there's a lot of cool stuff we could
do if there's a live stream going on at
the University like not my live stream
but sometimes a live stream events you
know it could show up there could be a
spot where if there is a live stream
it's gonna show up there right so that's
kind of the idea I have no idea if it'll
look right or if it will work or make
sense that's what we're gonna try today
I just glanced through the chat so
Philip said WordPress hearing that word
is killing me yeah
we're using a headless WordPress so it's
not it's not like the normal word press
that that everyone's used to using but
we tried to find an alternative and it's
not gonna happen for this project
maybe down the road we'll have something
alright so first thing we need to do is
find the index file so now let's get
into some code I will be using Visual
Studio code is a different project let's
switch this up okay we should find the
index page so we used next J s so um
increase the font size here in just a
second so we're using next to to build
this react site so next comes in with a
comes with a built in router and so any
anything you put in the pages folder
becomes a page in the site the home page
is indexed is so that's where we're
going to go now though the home page and
right eventually these will be added
into not dynamically but for right now
we we're just gonna count a hard code a
lot of it okay
we could probably leave some of these
cards up and just modify them a bit okay
let's go in here see what's what's going
on let's change this I know my boss
wanted more more buttons here so let's
add some more buttons
Saten apply button and we want I think
he also wanted a fly
inquire and visit so I I kind of think
we ought to just have one button I
generally like having one instead of
multiple ones so we're talking about
this button right here is called action
but he he wanted to have more than one
so you make this give this a more
realistic aspect ratio so we're gonna
I'm gonna try it I'm gonna show it to
him with three see how it looks and see
what happens yeah I definitely don't
want it like that if we're gonna do it
it's gonna be like this let's see we
really we're going to need this grid in
here so let's use we're gonna add a
great container component
good and then within that let's bring in
a great item
and
I'm gonna want three of these let's see
if we want it to be on extra small 12
will work but then anything other than
that yes six six the first one we wanted
to actually be 12 all the way up and
then after that we want it to be sorry
let me explain this a little bit more
the grid system is based on twelve
column layout so if we want it to be
full width we put twelve so on extra
small screens it's going to be full with
twelve columns on small screens and up
it's going to be half with six columns
so I'm gonna make a grid here and for
this one this top portion of the grid
it's gonna be like this otherwise if
we're gonna stick with these so I'm
gonna add in our buttons here and we
actually need to automatically change it
for me let's see what's up with these
lines is it just indentation yeah it is
okay so the main button that I want
users to see is gonna be the largest
button
and then let's put that visit button in
here as well and let's get rid of these
slashes okay if any of this is kind of
confusing to you let me know in the live
chat and then when we have our break
I'll see it and I can go back over and
try to explain some of it messed up my
indentation somewhere okay let's just
say that see whoa what did I do
all right this is all just annotation so
let's see grave container
let's go back over and see this should
not be
that's pretty weird
I'll see what's going on we are using
the latest version of material UI for
our layout so I still don't have a
familiarity with with that version of
material UI to know just offhand what to
do so I'll have to look up some things
which is not not the end of the world
I'm Shaughnessy okay all right I see
what's happening now all right that
makes sense
okay so here's what's happening the grid
container component is taking up the
full width here this button is taking up
full width so you can see it's gonna
show it all right yeah so this container
for that button you can see is full
width so let's um let's just shut change
this up a bit let's see what we have
here layout glasses see what we have
display flex limbs
all right just let's see what we should
we can change
okay let me get some suggestions here in
the live chat let's check that out
but Meyer or mayor is saying make it
inline rook saying justify content
Center on the Flex container okay we
have justify content center on on this
container here which is that's that
parallax section right what is this in
okay rook saying on the parent of the
button to centre okay let's do that then
we're gonna say alright so let's add on
these great items let's do a class name
and oops classes dots here Oh button and
then up here
let's make here a button class whoops
and we'll do justified contents Center
Center
okay so if this looks weird to you
it looks kind of like CSS but it's not
really CSS that's because whoops and
what did I do I mess something up down
here for some reason I added a square
bracket there we go
it works says add display flex as well
display flex
all right so within react there are many
different ways to do CSS I've messed it
up again that's why so I I meant to put
in equals and instead I put in a square
bracket and then I took out the square
bracket but didn't put the equal sign
back in okay so anyway this is one of
the ways that you can do CSS so you make
a JavaScript object and you you give it
it looks kind of like CSS right so we
have our classes so we have a class
called parallax and then within that
class we have all our properties here
and our values right so it looks
somewhat familiar but the syntax is just
a bit different it's the same syntax
you'd use in a normal JavaScript object
right so we have two camelcase
all of our properties then inside here
we could do things like we normally
would write because these are all
strings so that's how we're doing and
then when we go to apply this we were to
say class name classes thought parallax
okay
that's one way you could do it you can
see you know in the previous streams
we've tried out you know several
different ways of doing things
in fact even within this project we're
doing things like kind of a normal CSS
way here and we worked on this maybe two
or three streams ago so maybe you have a
lot of options with react so we're doing
it this way today and we may be doing it
a different way tomorrow on a different
page or different component but let's
check out and see what it looks like now
okay better better not exactly what we
what we want but much better so maybe
there might be a better way I think
there's a better way to do this I'm
gonna put this clock up here
all right
I don't think how I can make the make
sure I don't want a hard co2 value for
this button but that I mean that's
obviously the easiest way to do it all
right what do we have now for these
buttons maybe I do have something
hard-coded I have nothing
I have dev tools oh it looks like can
can everyone hear me there might be a
problem with the let me know if you
can't hear me uh-huh that doesn't make
sense what am I thinking all right let
me know if you can hear me I wish I
could edit the live videos because that
the last thing I said made me sound like
an idiot
I might be one who knows all right here
you can't see you
oh so my camera's out it's not even
there at all
man all right I'm gonna switch to my
other camera it's not as good of an
angle but at least it works man anybody
have any suggestions for a good camera
that I could get since my iPad camera
it's been cutting out all the time
lately
all right let's see
okay John John Hanson says has some
suggestions here flex div with three
buttons with just five okay
all right let's I know I know John knows
about the Flex CSS flex so just by
Senator I see so maybe I'll try that I'm
okay
only one flex container needed for all
three buttons okay
all right let's shut
alright I'm getting a lot of suggest
hints all right let's take this out also
let me see I see you I can get this
camera
maybe I hunts
let me read through some of these
suggestions
Phillips's CSS is like rocket science to
me always break stuff
yeah CSS it can be like that I think
it's fun sometime to mess around with it
and see what happens
okay Harsha says there's a some
documentation about doing this let me
check that out with trying to do this
with material UI
all right so actually let me pull this
over so since we already have the grid
layout here I guess we probably should
have done this already right we shoulda
checked out the documentation for how
grid works and what the options are so
this is material UI their latest version
this is a documentation on the grid
system
Harshit says we could check out the
interactive grid section
okay let's see
see I have this good
okay Meyer asks what's the final goal
for positioning the buttons in Aurora
okay
that yeah it might be helpful if I say
that okay the timer went off so let me
just finish this question and then we'll
do we'll take five minutes do some more
questions so the goal is to have the
apply button here and the apply button
is going to be the same width as the
inquiry and visit buttons combined so
you basically have apply and then right
underneath it it would say inquire and
then visit so inquiry and visit would be
side by side taking up half the space
half the width of the apply button the
apply on top when you're on a small
screen it would change and they would
all just stack and be the same all the
same size so that's the that's the idea
okay let's do short break and I'm gonna
scroll way up to the top of the live
chat there's no way I'm gonna get
through everything in five minutes here
so some of the questions that came later
on I'll have to wait until after the
next Pomodoro session let's see
oh okay Philip says Philip was talking
about the Pomodoro timer that he made
says I want to implement some kind of
stats just local using local storage but
I break it all the time I said that
would be kind of cool to do some sort of
statistics of so let me know do you have
this code on github for this this timer
I'd like to check it out if if that's
all right with you see us CloudFlare
yeah what did you use to to make this
oh [ __ ] said he's implementing let's see
oh cool oh I should put a dark theme on
his not too awesome I don't know it's
just like it seems like easier on your
eyes to look at the dark theme as
opposed to you know just all this white
it's just too bright
uh-uh razvan says do you have any lights
there or how do you look that good the
only light I haven't I have a very small
light just a little lamp but I have it
pointed like facing away so like facing
that way like up towards the opposite
direction that I am so it just provides
like a little bit of light and then the
light from my monitors that's the only
light yeah so it's I mean and then
obviously there's some light coming from
the hallway so you can see my door there
there's there's some light
okay Philip says there's also a plan to
turn it into a desktop app with electron
but I'm not sure if it can access the
file system since I would like to also
block websites with it I don't know does
anyone know that I'm not I mean it's
definitely possible to turn this into an
electron AB but I haven't worked with
lecture on that much to know very very
much about it
John says hopefully material design or
any styling set out there is not
copyright protected yeah as far as I
know material design like you can use
material design in in your projects
I think Google actually prefers that you
use it for Android apps especially so
there's no there's no copyright in the
sense that you can't actually use
material design principles
know what my youtube profile is if you
check in the description to this video I
do have a link to my youtube channel I
think it's the channel IDs like Jessie
or Y go I think
but anyway it's in the description for
this video so yeah if you want my I
don't update my channel nearly as much
as I upload videos here to free code
camp but I have a lot of ideas for
videos that I want to do I just I know
I've been saying for like being say for
like six months that I'm gonna add
videos and I haven't really added that
many but I would like to
all right so still have a lot left in
the live chat I'm gonna write down where
I'm leaving off at and I will come back
to that spot and keep answering
questions after our next coding session
here all right so if I didn't get to
your question yet please be patient I
will get to your question after we do
this next next coding session okay so
let's look at
okay Jordan and Q tube just joined and
are wondering what's what's going on so
for right now we're just trying to get
these three buttons aligned properly but
our goal or main goal is to try to get
some more content on this page just to
get an idea of what the layouts gonna
look like this is the home page of our
react site that we're building with next
j/s alright
all right let's um just autolayout
oh this kind of looks like what I want
I guess I could make two different
containers I don't think I really need
to do
all right so how did they do this your
small six
I don't know maybe that won't work
I was I scared of this for a second
okay so here's a great container we
could
we had a bunch of suggestions for this I
want to try to go through suggestions
basically whatever the easiest one to
implement is I want to try that first
and then move on to some of the the
harder ones so I think I remember seeing
one that would have been pretty easy
Oh maybe Johnson I don't know if John
was saying to make it row or that just
stick with the default as being row
which yeah it shouldn't change anything
the default is row right I thought it
was
so be creative or flex irritative to
sell your content
okay so yeah Roe is the default so I'm
going to remove that just as it's
unnecessary we need
and I'm really wondering if we should
just went with
this honestly would have been easier if
I just did all the CSS myself cuz now
I'm just trying to figure out how to do
it within the the grid system that comes
with materialized
let me see why
so I have dev tools open on my other
screen here I'm trying to figure out why
the width is what it is for this button
okay so I guess it's just based on the
the label size let's test that out yeah
okay so it is just based on the the text
that we have in there okay that makes
sense in this case I don't want that to
be the case though so let's try it let's
try just setting aside I kind of think
the surest way that we're going to get
this to look right is to kind of settle
this and you know just like absolute
units and just make sure that it's
narrow enough that it'll work on any
device and then we should be should be
all right I mean normally like you don't
want a hard code with like saying like
okay this is gonna be 200 pixels because
if somebody looks at your site on a
phone it'll it'll bleed over to the edge
right but if you make it so that the
pixels are definitely small I think the
smallest phone in terms of screen width
is like 320 pixels so as long as you're
below that then you should be alright
and we certainly don't need that much so
let's take a look at how many pixels
these buttons are taking up right now
so I'm not gonna bring dev tools over 56
okay so this one is 56 so if we go with
this being which I I like this size so
let's go with 56 so we're looking at 112
we're gonna hunt 212 pixels but we do
want a space that we want at least eight
pixel space in between these
so that actually that works out fine so
this button we're gonna make it 120
pixels wide and then we'll work on on
these here to get them to come in and be
right underneath there so first things
first let's check out our button my
button here raised let me show you
another way to do CSS in react so if you
wanted to just add something to one
element you're not going to reuse that
class you might want to think about
doing it like this okay so I'm I mean
everybody has their own preferences for
ways to do it but in this case I kind of
like to do it this way instead of making
a whole nother class so what we're gonna
do is say style and we're going to let
me do this was it - I think it's two
brackets and then we'll say I'm pretty
sure it's too right
well we'll find out they were gonna say
with yeah it is two brackets right
because the first set of brackets is
telling is saying hey we're going to do
some JavaScript the second set is an
object right and so we want this to be
an object so we're going to say with and
then we're gonna say 120 pixels right on
that button and let's see if it works
it looks wider let's double check and
the width is 120 pixels that really
doesn't look like it's gonna be wide
enough though let me see
oh you know what I looked at the wrong
size it was 88 pixels the total button
size so I was just looking at the size
of the text right so we got 88 pixels
okay so often make our button a little
bit bigger than 61 76 76 plus AIDS well
we got 184 I think 184
all right so we'll try that so 88 and 88
and then plus 8 pixels for space in
between I'm pretty sure you this one 84
all right so now let's try to move this
in I can just do in dev tools for now I
suppose so we have a line I am Center
going on here but we don't want
why do we even have it doesn't make any
sense
it's serious buttons going so
text
all right so
all right so we can add a justified
content
let's see there we go that's better flex
and flex to it
all right so if we add
hi oh let me check out
but another like since like start okay
John that's what I was a messing with in
in dev tools so and what is harsh it is
saying the OPR okay PR is up okay
alright we'll see what's what's going on
with harsha's PR in a second just to
show how we could do it potentially we
could go on this grid item and say hmm
Stiles let's just copy this we could add
a style into each one of these whoa
and the style could be justify content
and then we could do a flex and and then
on on this one we could do a flex start
and this [ __ ] aligned things okay see
and then we have things line up you know
like we wanted it and now probably this
is going to look yeah alright so I think
somebody mentioned it's gonna look weird
on mobile so we would definitely have to
add in you know at some point we would
need to have a media query to fix that
or actually potentially we wouldn't
right we could just do we could just
change this so that it's it's 6 all the
way let's see if that fixes it
yeah that actually fixes it we could get
a six over way it looks like this button
needs to be a bit wider though so maybe
my Matt oh you know I think my math was
right and we just have a larger gap in
between here then then I was thinking so
I actually like that gap I like that
size so I'm just going to go and keep
that but then adjust the see what do you
have here for padding okay so this is 16
pixels so if I just add any pixels onto
this button it should work
area
it doesn't look centered uh does it look
sent it to you something looks off maybe
it's just because the dogs I don't know
anyway let me check this
okay so harsh it has made a pull request
to so I guess let's check that out
and also there was I think Christian
mentioned in a in open and issue saying
we should update to the latest version
of material you I so we'll have to do
that I'm not going to do it on the
stream today but anyway if Christians
watching I just wanna let you know IIIi
did read that that issue and I will
update that soon
okay cool so check out harsh it's
alternative way of doing it here so this
is our same so we've he's added this
flex row class it just says display flex
and then also added margin you know and
margin eight pixels so Heath added the
class name flex row to a div and then
just through the buttons in there and
then just added that margin of eight
pixels for each one
be cool and actually question I'm
wondering though let's see okay alright
I just saw your message yeah cuz when I
read this I'm wondering that these would
align them all Center right but it
wouldn't it wouldn't be like I have the
side-by-side stuff so anyway thanks are
[ __ ] I guess we kind of stumbled on a
solution though here so for now this is
going to be okay just to give my boss an
idea of what it would look like if we
had three buttons I don't know why I
just I just keep looking at this and it
seems like now it looks better in a
smaller screen maybe it does have maybe
it is centered alright cool so we've got
that part finished let's let's at least
add in some things
John's saying it's an optical illusion
eightieth centers that's what I was
thinking I I'm kind of thinking on a big
screen because the dog's face is not
completely centered and it's more
obvious on a large screen that it
somehow throws this off for me you know
when you get smaller like here it looks
fine to me
but the dog's face is also centered
anyway and I mean the trust that is
centered all right let's check out this
card
we're gonna get rid of this card media
that's yeah I'm gonna get rid of the
media and okay good that's that's what
it should be doing and let's check out
the cards so I want to make a card
Titleist I just want to make see what
the title is components cars
okay let's see what they do for title oh
they just use typography headline okay
that works
I'll actually like it that way they put
it in actions or content okay car
content yeah why is this in actions this
should be in content and let's say this
is events and I see how it looks first
whoa Oh card content is not the fine we
have is will probably use card actions
at some points I'm going to leave it in
there we have fact we are using it for
the other card right now
okay cool and what we'll need is let's
grab some
we have some images
let's let's go to us flash about IT I'll
just grab a random image okay it's just
random I just wanted to double-check
what the URL was we'll need you know
what there's probably a component for
this what we want is a list grid lists
that we want
actually this grid list looks a lot like
what we're trying to do
like these grid list tiles I might have
to think about trying to adapt that to
use it for our whole layout but that's
not what we want right now let's check
out a regular list so I want a list that
includes an image there we go this is
what I want just make sure yeah all
right so - the checkbox I want the image
and this and then maybe we'll add a
description as well
Abbot's are okay
all right
let me throw in
within this card area in here we're
gonna put the list in there I'm just
gonna throw this in your shuttle lose it
right now and we're gonna need to bring
in we're gonna import list just import
the list item list under secondary
actions and we don't need the secondary
action do you need that and we need
avatar
okay now we can just pull in there
example stuff first and then modify it
and I think my timer just ran out so as
soon as I finish this I'll get to back
to the live chat all right so let's take
this and let's put it as the source and
let's make this square and what do we
want list item text we want for now
let's just say that one will completely
take out all this checkbox stuff and
all right we'll throw it in a couple of
times and
this side of three and we have classes
list items so we'll need to get that and
add it in as well so where's our list
item root Oh No
we pulling that in from somewhere else
mmm
let's see yeah we bring it in styles
maybe I ought to work you is not defined
oops I think I left in some
somebody's values for the key
value where I used to use oops
uh-uh
for
I saved that and see what we have now
what what did I do
alright well let's take out wash alright
let's actually take out typography as
well we don't need that
ha
thought I took out us you completely
I put them in the wrong spot ok bosz
makes more sense
and now let's see what happens hey there
we go alright ok so this is about what
we were looking for so we'll have events
and I will if I'm going to keep it like
this circle this obviously works if it
was really an avatar it looks fine
but potentially we might want you know
square images or something for events I
don't even know for one images at all
for events really but this would just be
something you know to look at you as a
placeholder alright not bad not as much
as I'd hope to get done these buttons
took way longer than I thought they
would but at least I had something so we
may end up working on this again
tomorrow we'll see this is our main
project now although we do have some
other things that need done alright let
me go back to live chat and I'm gonna
scroll up let's see alright so from here
on out I'm not going to do coding I'm
going to check out all the questions on
the live chat and try to answer as many
as I can when I get through everything
in the live chat then we will end the
stream ok so soft so ss0 pH says did you
learn JavaScript entirely on free code
camp no not entirely on free code camp
so I where did I start
probably it was a mixture of free code
camp and Udacity a lot of Udacity free
courses and just I guess I did code
Academy - those are like the main
resources but for more formal resources
online and then a lot of it was just
working on projects and looking up how
to do things so a lot of trial and error
John has a random math that will
autoplay a mix of images for those cards
oh maybe that was when I was explaining
what this was going to do yeah we may do
something like that
Irish it says the dark theme looks
awesome I should have made that dark
from the beginning
yeah the dark it does look cool I
started to make obviously for the
University we have light you know for
all things but for my like side projects
I started doing a lot more with with
dark themes so it is I think it looks
nice
let's see
Nerva is asking about what about react
do you know it very well I don't I don't
know I mean I I know it I built you know
I built things that work with it things
that are fast that that look pretty good
so I know enough to do that I wouldn't
say I'm an expert at react but I am
proficient I said would you would you
all say that's adequate explanation that
I am proficient and react I don't know
maybe I'm being too generous with myself
there
Philip asks if I have to specify all the
sizes for it to work I'm assuming Philip
you were talking about these sizes for
the grid you know what I don't know I I
thought I tried it before and I do have
to specify the sizes but I'm not a
hundred percent sure I wonder let's just
try to take these out and see
okay it looks good let's take these out
too
oh that still works
cool let's see can we take let me take
this up oops
so far so good
yeah actually I am only using the one
here so yeah it should be fine right
cool yeah so I'm not sure if that was
your question but if it was the answer
is no you don't need to define
everything I think as long as you define
the extra small it'll just by default
you'll use it for the other sizes that's
what it seems like so at least for now
it seems like everything's working in
and that's how it would work so I guess
it does make sense to not use them all
you could save a little bit of typing
Philip says do you prefer CSS or the
react CSS in the file Philip it kind of
depends on what I'm doing
so in this file I really don't mind so
what we're doing it we're trying to use
a lot of the components that come with
material UI and this is the way that all
the examples for material UI do things
so it actually is easier and it makes
more sense to just stick with that way
of doing things so I like this way
obviously I like to combine something
like this with some inline Styles where
appropriate so for instance this width I
think it makes sense to make this with
inline since we only use it once on one
component it ends up using you using up
less lines we actually don't even add a
line at all than if we were to create a
whole another class just to use it once
so I like that some people don't like
anything in line at all but I don't see
a problem with it when used like that
but then you know in something like our
faculty Jay s page where we actually
weren't we didn't have a lot of
components here but we were importing
all this other HTML and we needed to
style that then I really liked using the
regular CSS you know and just bringing
it in
so how are we importing that
I'm gonna remember how we brought that
in on oh we brought it we imported it
like this so I prefer that because
really I have to go to the page check it
out and dev tools do the changes I can
come back and do it in the CSS file I
don't have access directly to that that
markup from within my component so doing
it like this makes a lot more sense
is this how I have to do it
no I don't have to do it like that but
for me it just it it makes more sense to
do it like this then the haven't in here
you know like I don't want to have a
bunch of you know plus CSS classes here
for things that you can't even really
see in the component you know we're just
bringing this in it to me I think it
makes this component more reusable it's
obvious right that we are bringing in
some Styles here but really at any point
we could change this and make it a prop
and then we could potentially reuse this
now I know this is a page and it's in a
page in next but if we really wanted to
you know let's say in a somewhat
different situation this entire thing
could be reusable we just pop in a
different CSS file so it would make
sense to me you know so anyway it just
kind of depends
right
what's this Noreen says the mobile
version of the website downgrades the
user experience a lot the hover property
and the background attachment fixed are
no longer displayed any substitutions
for that are you talking about this site
I'm not that was marinus that so it may
be like just in general so on the mobile
I think background attachment fix
actually does work on Android at least
last time I tried I was pretty sure it
worked but you're right so on my LS
Mobile Safari it does not work as well
as the hover so which you still can get
is like a tap effect so right now like
the hover here let's see if I have it
okay so you see that effect that just
happens when I click it you can still
have that happen on touch so you get
obviously you're not gonna have a hover
on on a touchscreen right but you can
still get some effect on the button that
ripple and then with the background
thing you could do two things one you
could just make it so that your
background attachment is not fixed you
switch it over with a media query to
something like maybe static and then you
just don't get that parallax effect
anymore that works it's it's okay or if
you wanted to keep the parallax effect
you could switch over and use some
JavaScript to give you that same
parallax effect okay a little bit
heavier but you get the same user
experience on a mobile device and a
desktop so I guess it just depends on um
you know what you want to do for a site
let's say that maybe he's not going to
get a lot of mobile use maybe you don't
want to worry about it but for
site that's going to be you have a lot
of mobile users you may want to think
about one with the JavaScript your
parallax scrolling effect
filibus if the timer gave a notification
zone I don't remember hearing a
notification sound so I don't know I
wasn't really paying attention though I
saw a notification pop up on my screen
but I didn't hear the sound but it I
mean I'm listening to music too so
depending on what the sound was it could
have happened and I just wasn't paying
attention didn't hear it over the music
hey Brooke says I'm gonna mess around
with a fork of this project
awesome rook you're welcome to make a
pull request if you want or if you take
it in another direction and do some cool
stuff with it let me know I'd love to
check it out
YouTube says that dog is adorable yeah
it is I love this stuff my my wife's
parents have a dog that looks just like
this it's actually it looks like it's
it's fatter than this one but but anyway
they have a dog like this and her name
is lilo but it always reminds me of her
no not like the dog it is so cute it's
distractingly cute Philip says I wish I
was that dog Noreen says the dog is
smelling the button yeah this looks like
that Philip says can we get a dog
instead of Jessie nothing personal just
haha I might actually get more viewers
if I just had a dog sitting here and you
could see the dog I can still do the
voice-over and do the coding but if you
just saw a video of a dog instead of my
face that might be a better viewing
experience I don't know if I could bring
a dog in to work done I have to say if I
if I ever get better internet in my
house maybe I'll borrow someone's dog
and we'll try it out
[Music]
povel says I just joined what's this
project about today we were just working
with aligning some buttons and creating
this card that displays events but the
project in general is going to be the
main website for the university that I
work for it's Franciscan University of
Steubenville we're building it with
react specifically we're using next js'
mainly for the server-side rendering
that it offers and we're migrating a lot
of data from another database into a
WordPress my sequel database and then
we're going to pull that data with graph
QL into our react application if you
want to know more about the project go
back and watch some of the previous
videos especially the first few videos
for project 5 and you'll get a much more
thorough explanation of what we're
trying to do here
q two bass what does typography do so
type art let's see I have it somewhere
whoops let's go over to index soak you
tube is asking about the typography
element here so when you're using
material I the the beta version they
have this element called typography and
you can give it a type and depending on
the type anything in here will display
differently so subheading will display a
certain way you could do different kinds
of headings right like h1 h2 you could
do regular body text like paragraph text
so you know you can check out the the
documentation for material you I beta on
typography and see all the options that
are available but basically anywhere
where you want text to display you could
just do typography and then add a type
and that's how you would display your
text so you're you're almost never gonna
see just a paragraph tag or an H tag you
know just hanging out here when you're
using material you I beta version you
certainly could put it in there but
material UI you know has you covered
with this typography component I'm sorry
not a component but I guess it is it is
a component we just never worked
directly with with it as a component
here but but it is I I don't know why I
was calling it something else but you
import it from
yeah from mature UI huh look says is
that a dinner bell I hear it sorry I'm
hungry what was it oh yeah it was so it
it's not a dinner bell but pretty close
like right across the hallway from my
office there's a bell on the wall and
there's like a little room like a little
prayer room and at three o'clock pretty
much everyday at 3 o'clock they ring the
bell and then people go in there and
they pray you know for everybody in the
office and whatever else they want to
pray for so but I usually do my streams
during that time so if you do hear a
bell around it's 3 p.m. my time eastern
time that's what it is
okay Philip says by the way one thing to
always remember if you're working with a
wordpress site if you move it from live
to local environment remember to change
database settings or you might new calf
of your live site
yeah I've moved a lot of WordPress sites
over the years so it's always good to
have the reminder though but yeah you
got to be careful when you're moving and
it doesn't always work out how you think
it would work out
moving WordPress sites is is only it
seems more complicated then then you
would would want it to be than it should
be but and I don't do it often enough to
remember exactly how I did it every time
so I always have to look up the
instructions for how to properly move it
but we'll probably move it on a stream
or something so that might be a cool
stream to do
Jordan s if this is on github it is it
is on github the repo I think is called
let's see do I have the repo up I
thought I did yeah the repo is called
Franciscan react
and actually I should I'll push the
changes up now that I never pushed
changes from this faculty dot CSS I
guess not Wow sorry to anyone who was
trying to look at this I guess I forgot
to put changes push changes from weeks
ago
all right so I'm going to commit that
and then I'll push it list is the fine
but never used in forest
wait did I mess this up I did all right
let's wrap this in a list
I mean it still worked but I'll try to
do this the proper way
I think sure it still looks alright
there's aphasia
okay cool still works
now it's going to run a bunch of checks
it's going to do the tests it's going to
do some formatting some Auto formatting
in the code if it passes everything
obviously linting as well but if it
passes everything then we'll have a
successful commit awesome and says I
should update NPM now we can go git push
origin since one of the master branch no
I did turn my computer off when I wasn't
here over over the break so I need to
put this in again
okay so now our game repo should be
updated if I could find it is there any
windows open
there it is all right cool
so we did have so you do have everything
updated at this point
okay.i by boat oh I think that's how you
pronounce it says is asking about the
theme in Visual Studio code hard said it
is the SETI theme i but i wanted to know
what exactly the name was references
where do I go I don't even know where I
go to change the maybe setting you know
I just found it no color theme yeah
actually it's just SETI SETI that's the
name of the the theme
I said the repo has not been updated in
two weeks yeah that was my fault we had
done work on the stream and I just
forgot to push the changes up to the the
repo do we have any other we did have
some other branches too but right now
the one actively being worked on is the
master branch Sergio says ask do you
recommend Udacity front-end
certification I've done a lot of the
Udacity courses for that front-end
certification the free versions of them
so some courses on Udacity you have to
pay to get any access to it all other
ones you can go through the course for
free you just won't get your projects
reviewed by anybody at Udacity so the
review is valuable so if you have the
money and the time I think it it is
really valuable to do the product the
paid version of the projects I don't
know if the certification helps that
much you know to let's say put that on a
resume
I don't really know maybe for companies
that have hired people from Udacity and
are you happy with those those people
the work that they do
maybe it'll mean something to them but I
don't know that Udacity is well known
enough that it'll like guarantee you a
job but the when you turn in a project
for Udacity you're doing the paid
version and you get the feedback from
someone that's really really valuable
it'll push you to make better projects
so like I said if you have the time and
the money I do recommend it but don't
feel like you have to you can certainly
still get a you know a lot of the
knowledge from the free version of the
course and then if you ever get a time
where you do have some more time or more
money then you can do the paid version
and you already are
head of the game because you've gone
through a lot of it but yeah I would for
sure check out the free version of the
courses think about doing the paid
version I'm not affiliated with Udacity
in any way so that's just my honest
opinion so I have done the free and the
paid version of some of the courses and
I think there's good content on Udacity
see work says why does free code camp
seem to focus on front-end development
why we why don't they cover the back end
they actually do have back in lessons it
just comes later on so if you look at
you know the free code camp website
we'll check it out right now
let's see know what the map here we go
so you can see I only have 285 points
but you know all this stuff at the
beginning is front-end but you get here
there's a data visualization
certification then we have the backend
so there's a whole section that's for
the backend that's just you know a lot
of people if they're trying to go in
order a lot of people don't get to that
point it takes a lot of work to get
there you know for me I started going
through free code camp and then I just I
got too much paid work and I started
doing that and just kind of didn't get
around to you know it's finishing it I
love to finish it one day just not not
right now I'll probably wait until the
new curriculum comes out to do anything
more with it but we do in fact have back
in a back end certification and we have
a lot of backend projects
kaathal says does anyone know a good
autoformat package for visual studio
code for react brooke says prettier plus
es lint kaathal says thanks had to stop
using it because of the formatting
hopefully that fixes it okay yeah that I
I use the prettier es lint setup as well
Thao says are you doing this with
bootstrap no not bootstrap we're using
material UI the beta version of material
UI so it's a react it basically it does
what bootstrap does for regular HTML
sites it does that for react and it uses
the material design style mayor says I
did a pull request please check cool off
to check this up
button layouts
there's some logic to her
okay all right cool thanks mayor off to
check this out let's see
this is Jesse we need to code we did if
you're joining us later on we finished
the coding portion so normally if you
join me in a live chat for like the
first hour or so that's when we do the
majority of the coding and then the last
part of the live stream is when I answer
the questions so you can check out the
code portion of it on the recording in
this video and if you don't want us hang
around for the questions and all the
talking just skip that part of the video
so actually that's good I know I've had
people before say they like the code
part not so much the talking part so
maybe in that case the live stream isn't
really the best thing for you if you
wait and watch the recording you could
watch it
you could either skip the talking
altogether or just play it on a fast
speed and then slow it down when the
code part comes so that I think that's a
great way to do it if you don't have a
lot of time or if you're just you know
really want to you know see the coding
you know skip to like some part that's
interesting for you so - anyway for
anybody that is in that situation you
know give that a try I love to Admiral
for the live chat but I totally
understand if it's if it's too time
consuming or if I'm just too boring to
listen to
I I get that too
rook says that that PR from Mayor is
great
cool I'll have to often check out how
this looks after the stream too is too
much says what is your project
it's a react project it's going to be
the main website for Franciscan
University of Steubenville so just
really quickly we're using react we're
going to do server-side rendering we're
pulling the data from a wordpress
wordpress installation that's using
graph QL so we're going to get the data
out of that and display it with react
alright and that's it I'm to the end of
the live chat so thank you all for for
watching and if you asked the question
and I I skipped over it
that was definitely accidental so you go
ahead and send me a question on Twitter
if you want or put it as a comment to
this video or just wait till the next
live stream and ask asked the question
be happy to ask I'll be happy to help
you all out with anything I can and I
should be back what is today today's
Wednesday Wow ok so I should be able to
stream tomorrow around the same time so
somewhere on maybe 1 or 2 p.m. Eastern
Time
so until then thanks again for watching
and have a great day